what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to boyfriend set's up
girlfriend to see if she will cheat
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification bell while you're at it
check out my sweatshirts i absolutely
love these um they're super simple which
is like my style and i like the teal
with the blue
and
they go with anything to be honest and
the material is really soft
okay
i'm done hyping these up i'm done i i
really like them i'm excited about them
check them out okay
and by the way the scene is the
boyfriend is
setting up the girlfriend like he's
trying to sell her the the hot guy is
like trying to sell her a car someone
else to come with her hopefully they
will say that they couldn't because they
had to work now granted yes alexa could
have just told alex to reschedule to a
different day but we try to be ready for
that too in one of the initial texts the
alexandalexia we had him emphasize that
he was going out of town and could only
show alexia the car at his preferred day
and time being that the car was such a
good deal alex also told alexia that he
couldn't guarantee that the car would
still be available at a later date
[Music]
and then finally and most importantly we
had a j vouch for alex this would
hopefully ensure that alexia wouldn't
think that alex was a creep is it
illegal to ride butt naked in your own
car
i feel like that should be legal if you
have tents right and so with all of our
bases covered as best as we could cover
them and with alexia on her way all that
was left to do now was simply wait soon
enough after about a good 20 minutes
alexia ended up giving alex a call that
she was here
hello oh alex is getting a call on his
phone i'm here i just parked i'm
not sure where you're at
all right let me get out and look for
you
oh i think i see you over there
so alexia just gave alex a call right
now that she is here
did you see her pull in i didn't even
see her pulling alex right now is
getting out of his car and going towards
her he is waving her down it looks like
okay there she is oh she parked all the
way over there wow oh let's get this
popping
don't worry about it you're getting your
steps in
okay here we go you ready for this she
better not fall for it she's making he's
already making her walk hella far and
stuff it's already a bad bad situation
how you doing
how are you i can't complain do you have
a good drive over yeah
the traffic
yeah i'm alex
alexia alexia nice to meet you so after
days of preparation hours of setting up
and about 30 minutes of just waiting
around alexia had finally arrived and
this test was officially underway here
we go man
[Music]
this is what you're getting it's 2020
see super new super clean
as planned alex gets right into it and
begins letting alexia check out the car
check out the
house it only has about like six
thousand seven thousand miles on
other than a little bit of bird dookie
on it it's real clean yeah
i really like the brand i said hey throw
the black ones on there you know
oh my gosh why does he like why is he
talking like that get in get in check it
out
alexia jumps into the car and begins
checking out the interior everything so
far has gone off without a hitch but
this is where things could have gotten
dicey remember in the backseat of the
car we had our hidden camera and we
didn't want alexia to find it because
then she's either gonna get suspicious
or really creeped out so to prevent this
from happening we locked the rear doors
and prayed that alexia was cool with
checking out the back seats from the
front of the car i'm gonna take that
charger with me
you're gonna get the car just oh nothing
extra
okay
why are you getting rid of this car
i just i have a couple other cars i
don't need it plus it's always good to
help somebody out right i could just go
sell it back to a dealership or some
[ __ ] like that
if you need it we can work something out
another way that we try to prevent
alexia from finding her camera was by
having alex emphasize and draw her
attention more to the exterior features
of the car versus the interior you see
how i turn the tire right here just a
little bit give you that fast and
furious look that fast and furious look
with the tire right here do you guys
feel like he has game i do not i will be
shocked if she goes for this shocked
i don't even know what number they're on
right now freaking infinity what do you
think what are your thoughts on alex
he's cool he's a really cool guy you
know you got the height and everything
else i guess but you know it's the
height
that's all it takes nowadays just be six
three six
shots let's pop the trunk short king
short king plenty of room back here i
don't know what you get down with okay
my trunk doesn't have like
this it's like literally cardboard and
carpet cardboard and carpet
so we're upgrading on the how are you
feeling so far how how is it so far it's
not looking too crazy so far but i don't
know this guy's has a lot to say he has
a lot of personality dude
i'm sweating in this car man
alex has a lot of personality dude he's
got great personality
he makes everyone just feel very
comfortable you know so all right so
what you thinking like
can you see yourself in this
completely going out saturday night
yeah i need to take the windows a little
bit a little bit yeah oh you don't want
to be seen huh what kind of car did you
currently drive it says
uh she drives a malibu 2012. oh nice not
a bad car honestly
isn't it something bad 2012 you said it
was
uh you want to
bend the block
take it for a little test drive
all right
yep
immediately oh is he gonna make his move
now
let's see
so after checking out the car alexia was
now ready to take it for a test drive
which means that we are inching closer
and closer to the moment where alex will
be offering alexia the car for free in
exchange for going on a date with him
okay so they're off so we're gonna lose
him on the mic right here i'm hoping she
makes me proud
get my fingers crossed fingers and toes
crossed the thing
i i think she's
gonna turn him down i feel like that guy
doesn't really have that much game
and she doesn't see that indeed we have
lost them on the mic because they've
gone out of range so they left for the
test drive everything seems like it's
going good though though so far so good
man so far so good let's hope it stays
that way yeah how you feeling i know
it's always weird hopping into another
car
just driving with the car
it feels like way smoother than my car
okay do you think anything's gonna
happen in the test drive
do you think we're gonna miss something
well she better focus on the road so
nothing's gonna happen
the good thing is is that there's a
camera rolling inside of the car so if
anything after the test we'll be able to
like watch it and listen in to see
exactly what happens but i don't think
anything is going to happen i think
they're just going to test drive it
bring it back here and then that's when
alex is going to make his move and you
know what i like the optimism you like
me out there good job i like that
nothing will happen let's manifest it
nothing at all is going to happen
nothing is going to happen
yeah bluetooth oh my gosh i thought
those were all like hookups here like
the charger
charged 10 phones charging back
i mean feel free to open it up a little
bit you can go faster than 30. alrighty
so on a scale of one to ten how
confident do you feel right now i'm
gonna call it i think that she
she's gonna turn him down
honestly i feel like
a five out of ten like i'm confident but
i'm also pretty nervous because you
never know that's good under the right
circumstances anybody can fold right
right so
exactly crazy are you prepared for the
possibility that she might feel this
test i don't know i have more faith in
her than anything
[Music]
after a good 10-minute test drive alexa
eventually makes her way back to the
park oh here they are okay we have them
coming back okay we got we have that
coming back guys we have connection
again now in order to get alexia in
perfect line of our cameras once again
we made sure to tell alex to instruct
her on where to park
i feel like that's a black people thing
black people always back in the partners
the moment of truth has finally arrived
alexia has checked out the car she has
test driven it and alex will now offer
her a huge fat quote unquote discount
the question now is will alexia remain
loyal to her boyfriend jay or will she
be willing to trade him for a
relationship with alex and a brand new
car
the car might do it but i don't
i don't think so i don't think so
all right so what you thinking man i
know uh he told you the budget
yeah i could do it though yeah okay
before we go any further i have to
address something here see unfortunately
after getting back from the test drive
alex's mic didn't reconnect well and it
kept cutting in and out here check it
this is alex's mic track this is before
the test drive this is during the test
drive and this is after the test drive
see all these dips these are the moments
where alex's mic completely cut out and
we couldn't hear anything unfortunately
we didn't have any backup audio and at
one point in this conversation the mic
completely cut out for good so in
summary the audio will sound like [ __ ]
at some points and i'll be voicing over
other portions and yeah i apologize i'm
really really sorry i was honestly not
gonna upload this video because of this
reason but i decided to because trust me
it's still gonna be
i'm saying you looking real cute in the
car so i feel like you should really
take this off my hands
i throw you a nice little deal um
i don't know what you got going on but
if you want to actually like maybe go
out sometime i'll throw you a deal even
better deal yeah
i mean we could throw some thousands up
or depending on how we vibe we can i
just give it to you
you wouldn't i told you like i'll i'll
bowling ball this car down the street
not even give a [ __ ] i mean i'm trying
to help you out anyway like you know
what i'm saying my boy said you needed
some help so trying to upgrade we can
put you in this have you look in this
right here i know you said you wanted to
oh no this freaking might keeps getting
out oh jesus rj sergeant is mike is
either not reconnecting well or we're
just too freaking far now so one of the
first moments where am i cut out was
when alex was describing to alexia the
kind of date that he would take her on
oh no i think already
she's taken this too far i had faith in
you
faith in you if she accepted his offer
luckily though we didn't miss much and
we were able to somewhat re-establish a
connection with alex's mic
we can go rooftop pool even though
you're hooking it up but yeah i mean
[ __ ] you can leave your wallet at home
if you want to it's really no big deal
oh what the heck
oh she's passing really an option
why all you gotta do is get in the car
right now honestly like i got a little
bit of free time before we gotta go we
can just go talk about it
oh wait so she did the right thing so
far maybe maybe she comes through
yeah yeah we could discount just a
little we can call it like a little
first date how about that
i don't know you know think about it too
just go
about it
ah this freaking thing keeps cutting out
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
try to read her body language if
anything
did you not see how good we look
together in that car how many come on
i don't know
i mean i feel like you already know
we'll have a lot of fun
this guy is not smooth like that
look at the conversation already like
and then he'll just like sit there and
be like
and i'll just be like can you see
anywhere just like
okay
this is me
this is me no you're like nah ah no i'm
not that person i'm not that person
phone stay in my pocket you get my under
fighter attention
yeah it's like going out i'm all yours
wait wait
what
i had faith in you oh my god this is
like a roller coaster
oh
yay you gonna pass you're gonna pass me
and the deal yeah
that's what i love to hear
my heart
damn rejected is he getting rejected
ah man i gotta give it to you full price
you playing around
now i'll just play it actually give you
a discount but are you sure like i'm
gonna give you a little think about it a
couple more times cuz
that's are you playing
around sorry sorry we're losing them
here now this is where oh look at he's
so happy she's my completely cut out for
good but from what we heard and after
continuing to analyze alexia's body
language it appeared as if she was just
not going for it okay we can't hear
anything anymore and i'm not trying to
get your excitement jade but it looks
like she is saying no
oh
[ __ ]
see look at it look at guys
faith in women restore
i wasn't worried at all man
yeah
she passed rejected
i feel so good
wow i'm so happy when i'm proud of her
man so what a lot of you guys may not
know because we hardly post passes on
this channel is that whenever someone
passes the test we always have
contingency plans obviously alex really
isn't selling this card but we can't let
alexia know that see it's not our job or
place to tell alexia that this was all a
test jay's gotta be the one to do that
so to continue making this entire
scenario seem real alex told alexia that
he was taking the car to get detailed in
about two hours and that if she really
wanted it she could take it off his
hands then
all right so now what do we just let her
walk is she she's leaving you don't even
have time to do you want to catch up to
her
[Laughter]
this is such a feel-good a feel-good
show
we love to see it man hey hey but that's
good for you bro yeah yeah right she's
the one that's what it looks like we got
to get married now
absolutely not man i think i'm just
having a secret for right now you'll go
keep that to yourself yeah how many
views did this get oh my gosh two
million yeah it's time to see that's the
most important thing that's all i care
about
okay so i want to ask you guys two last
and final questions the first question
is do you guys think alexia passed the
test i personally think that she did now
do you guys agree or do you guys
disagree being able to look back at the
footage now and being able to make up
the audio a little bit better it did
sound like alexia was thinking about it
however maybe she was just thinking
about it because she felt awkward or
uncomfortable or maybe she was just
being nice i don't know i think she
passed i'm gonna say she passed but what
do you guys think let me know in the
comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell
and i'll talk to you guys next time